the police have no place at pride  let me be clear if you are a police  officer professionally as your job i am  not saying that you cannot participate  in a pride event if you yourself are one  of the uh associated identities or even  if you are an ally but on duty police  have no business  being at a pride event  the police are an extension of state  power  and lgbtqia plus people are currently  oppressed  in many many ways  by state power  around the world and in this country the  very first pride was a riot against the  police  and that should never be forgotten  and we  do not need your protection  and your presence  only extends to attempt to intimidate us  and we won't have it